قلقوا بكين وواشنطن من خطوره استخدام
السيارات الكهربائيه كشواسيس متحركه انعكس
عبر سلسله قوانين طلب بها مشرعون او بدا
العمل بها بالفعل في مارس 2001 2021 اصدرت
السلطات الصينيه قرارا بمنع دخول سيارات
تسلا الى مقارات المباني الحكوميه
والمؤسسات الحساسه كما اجبرت تسلا على فتح
مركز البيانات لتخزين جميع البيانات في
سياراتها في الصين نحن في العام ذاته لكن
في يونيو
بكين اي سياره تسلم من السير في منتجع في
اقليم لمده شهرين وما هو السبب
المنتجات كان مقر التجمع السنوي للمسؤولين
الحاليين والسابقين في الحزب الشيوعي
بعدها باسبوعين تكرر الامر في مدينه
شنغندو وهذه المره السبب زيارته الرئيس
اما واشنطوا لنا فتاخرت عن بكين في تشريع
القوانين ربما للشغاله هذه سيه واوي
وتكتوك لكن ان تاتي متاخرا خيرا من الا
تاتي اصلا الجمهوريون بداوا في الضغط على
اداره السلامه على الطرق السريعه لفرض
قيود على السيارات الصينيه وربما اغلبيتهم
من مجلس النواب يساعد ان تنافس قائم على
التفوق في صناعه السيارات الذكيه ذاتيه
القياده ايضا والافضليه مع بكين التي
تتفوق في معدن الكباب وبطريات الليثيوم
وحتى ان بعض التقديرات الامريكيه تشير الى
ان حصه السيارات الكهربائيه والذاتيه
القياده الصينيه في السوق الامريكيه قد
تصل مستقبلا الى 10% من اجمالي عدد
المركبات في الولايات المتحده